ari boulogne bonsoir soit alors vous
êtes le fils de nicolas super star des
sixties ex mannequin égérie d'andy
warhol du velvet underground le mythique
groupe de lou reed vous aimez nicolien
dustan je suis hyper fan de nico de voir
les toute cette époque bien alors votre
père c'est un père qui ne vous a pas
désigné pour fils puisque alain delon a
toujours refusé de reconnaître cette
paternité et vous quand vous parlez de
lui vous dites moi je ne demande rien
mais qu'il ne m'accuse pas d'être un
imposteur car dans ce cas qu'il prouve
que je ne suis pas son fils et qu'il
fasse un test sanguin c'est bien votre
déclaration tout à fait pourquoi il l'a
jamais fait à votre avis
est ce que il s'est tenu jugement rendu
en mai wright débouté ça devait être en
163 je pense un peu après ma naissance
et il n'est pas de tests adn à cette
époque là et depuis
j'ai entamé une procédure de
reconnaissance ans quand j'avais 18 ans
qui a été zappé quoi ouais voilà ce dont
on est sûr c'est que alain delon a fait
au moins une fois l'amour et votre main
oui oui ça y est vous l'a dit ça il vous
l'a dit tout le monde le sait alors vous
êtes né donc de nico et peut-être
d'alain delon puisque jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas été prouvé en
1962 à la clinique du belvédère à
neuilly votre nom de naissance c'est
celui de votre mère c'est une belle game
1 et votre prénom c'est aaron dit harry
puisque la veille votre mère avait vu au
cinéma exodus paix newman dans le rôle
de aron baynes cannes vous pensez que
c'est peut-être pour effacer le le péché
des allemands qu'elle vous a appelé
comme ça donnait un nom hébraïque
peut-être
c'est une possibilité oui vous avez
parlé avec elle
non
alors plus tard on vous appellera ari
boulogne du nom de la mère d'alain delon
qui s'appelle et évite boulogne on va
voir comment on va voir pourquoi c'est
une histoire incroyable
vous racontez ça beaucoup d'autres
choses dans un livre qui s'appelle
l'amour n'oublie jamais qui est édité
chez pauvert
mise en vente 40000 exemplaires en douce
pourquoi peur des avocats
non je ne savais pas même je savais pas
combien d'exemplaires était de tirer
donc quarante mille mais ça a été mis en
vente en 12 104 je sais je sais ce que
j'étais même pas sorti
alors on va en parler interview vérité à
la bouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien donc à ari boulogne
sur effectivement vous ressembler
beaucoup alain delon on vous le dit dans
la vie comme ça on ne le dit oui souvent
les gens vous disent dans la rue dans la
rue ça m'arrive c'est plus les
chauffeurs de taxi ouais voilà ils vous
disent comme ça les gens taxi vous
n'êtes pas le fils d'alain delon vous y
en a même un qui était alors là on à dos
avec lui un jour et à berlin ça m'est
arrivé ouais parce que parfois ça
m'emmerde un brin con con qu'on parle de
ça donc j'ai dit non non vous vous
trompez de personnes
et puis à berlin quand je tournais nikon
il ya un chauffeur de taxi
mais vous êtes le fils de mehdi mais
bien sûr mois ci mais s'il est ce qu'il
est c'est sympathique l'humain les
avocats d'alain delon quand on leur
parle de vous disent que c'est des
coïncidences morphologique
c'est un peu facile
le plus incroyable dans votre histoire
si vous avez eu deux vies parallèles
aussi dissemblables que possible d'un
côté avec nico votre mère permissivité
absolue chez les hippies de new york
d'ibis à vous aider a pris goût à
l'arrêt à l'héroïne auprès de auprès de
cette bande de gens auprès de votre mère
et de l'autre côté les règles
moralisante de bourg la reine puisque
vous avez été recueillis d'une certaine
façon par la mère et le beau père
d'alain delon et vous dormiez comme vous
étiez petit dans le lit où avaient été
conçus alain delon élevé dormi avant
vous et et finalement vous aviez un pied
dans la banlieue comme ça et et un autre
dans des endroits les plus dans les
endroits les plus bizarres de la planète
non oui jusqu'à l'âge où il a fallu ma
mère ne pouvait plus s'occuper de moi de
par son travail il fallait qu'elle
assure au jour le jour ça c'est quoi ce
qu'était payer 5 dollars la journée elle
ne concerne donc plus aux côtés de
moelle appelé ma mère ma grand mère
pardon qui est venu me chercher donc à
new york alors évidemment le summum de
votre enfant c'est donc d'abord
effectivement d'avoir vécu ces deux vies
parallèles et surtout quand votre mère
nico du velvet underground débarqué à
bourg-la-reine parce que d'un seul coup
elle débarquer en banlieue et vous vous
convier à inversement quand vous aviez à
new york et que vous alliez à la factory
de warhol et que vous parliez à ces
gens-là de dorothée la tortue que vous
aviez dans le jardin de bourlingue vous
avez une enfance complètement
schizophrénique absolument
alors effectivement d'un côté il y avait
les deux pharmacies à pour la reine la
pharmacie martin lavigne un bourg la
reine et de l'autre côté il se baladait
sur les épaules de bob dylan au jardin
du luxembourg en lui caressant les
cheveux enfin c'est une vie assez assez
étonnante alors ce livre bon et consacré
d'abord avant tout je dirai au culte de
votre mère c'est un culte qui s'est
forgée à la factory c'est pas là que
tout a commencé gastien aussi alors elle
c'était la superstar ans comme on disait
à l'époque super rizla oui c'était là la
suite à tort dans les warhol et vous
quand vous alliez à la factory très
jeune c'était un peu la mascotte winfakt
ouellet
et donc vouloir servir un petit peu des
fois de couverture quand j'avais des
centres de données parce que j'étais
très très galoper par tous temps vous
les aidiez quand il avait des flics qui
débarque à la factory est alors en même
temps je les fais des films avec eux et
journée dans j'irai jouer dans chelsea
games est un film de paul maurice est un
exploitant 84
alors un jour un espion envoyé par là
par la famille bolen donc la famille
d'un de l'eau on vous voit la factory
finir des verts après en fin de soirée
tout petit que je vous aviez j'avais
entre quatre et cinq ans voilà il
finissait des verts il avaler des
pilules qui était dans le sac de sa mère
d'ailleurs à 4h30 vous avez une hépatite
et la mère d'alain delon donc edit
boulogne est venu vous récupérez à new
york c'est cela et vous à embarquer dans
ce pavillon à bourg la reine elle édite
boulogne la mère de l'un d'eux l'on est
persuadé vous êtes le fils de son fils
tout à fait un la direction du zèle at
il écrit oui elle a écrit vous
reproduisez une lettre dans votre book a
alors elle édite boulogne la mère de
l'un d'eux l'on vit avec monsieur
boulogne qui est son second mari en fait
c'était son second mari qui était un
type assez bizarre parce qu'il avait
beaucoup bu ils étaient murées sur
l'image mentale et quand j'ai quand je
les connais ils avaient arrêté de boire
a été quelqu'un effectivement qui ne
disait pas grand chose c'est quelqu'un
de très cartésien de très simple mais
j'avais beaucoup d'affection pour lui
j'ai toujours beaucoup d'affection pour
lui
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a permis de
découvrir la pêche par exemple des
choses simples comment faire une épice
sûrs dont c'était quelqu'un de mairie
donc en paix alors en fait ce monsieur
boulogne n'était pas le père d'amar le
père de l'indolence et fabien 2 millions
qui est partie du domicile conjugal
quand alain delon avec quatre ans
refaire sa vie pas très loin d'ailleurs
dans la même banlieue et vous l'avez vu
vous il n'a pas refait sa vie et il n'a
pas il a pas bougé de la maison qu'ils
habitaient disait ma grand mère qui a
fait sa vie avec monsieur vous donne
mais vous l'avez vu vous ce fabien delon
je les ai vus attendant son bus way we
quand j'étais donc quand j'étais jeune
quand et et quand ce fabien delon était
parti alain delon a été confiée à des
familles d'accueil et on peut lire sur
le site internet alain delon en ce
moment que il a été confié à une famille
d'accueil à fresnes enfin ceci explique
aussi beaucoup de choses telles qu'alain
delon se retrouve en train de jouer dans
la cour d'une prison puisque sa mère ne
s'occupant pas de lui il avait été
confié à une famille d'accueil à fresnes
alors faut dire que question antécédents
vous avez une lourde hérédité puisque
l'autre grand père serre le le père de
nico votre grand père maternel et
opiomane
aïe ça fait beaucoup à ma mère est ma
mère est née opiomane we hope you man
vivait dans un house boat ces bateaux
qui n'a qu'un fleuve à srinagar donc au
début des années 30 amis de gandhi et
dans votre mère est née de par là même
vous dites opiomane ce qui explique oui
elle est née avec une double pneumonie
ouais donc elles étaient organisées
explique sur l'addiction à l'héroïne oui
à ces jeunes quoi
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire finalement un
resplendissant l'autre
bien sûr oui c'est une femme les serres
détruites palais rhône ah ça fait quoi
ça ne détruit pas
la preuve cette journée moi aussi j'en
prends
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire harry
finalement que comme la mère d'alain
delon c'était pas bien occupé de son
fils puisqu'il avait été mis dans les
familles d'accueil on vient d'en parler
à fresnes est-ce qu'on veut pas dire
qu'elle vous a couvé d'une certaine
façon vous pour s'amender pour se faire
pardonner d'une certaine façon oui je
pense oui ouais
sans aucun doute parce que c'était elle
mélangeait les noms des tendances à
naples et al ouais rien donc alors c'est
une vie un sens c'est parce que quand
vous êtes à bourg-la-reine vivait avec
la présence de ce père qui ne vous
reconnais pas à photographier et à la
télévision il a en photo il hanté à vue
dites dans votre livre la télé semble
n'avoir été inventée que pour passer des
films d'alain delon et quand il dit sa
mère donc votre grand mère le voilà
terrell il a des valeurs sous les yeux
enfin c'est une espèce de promiscuité
médiatique incroyable oui et un jour il
yal'affaire marco vic donc c'est que
c'est l'assassinât du garde du corps
d'alain delon une affaire a beaucoup
parlé à l'époque et à ce moment là vos
grands-parents donc monsieur boulogne
edit boulogne par peur peut-être d'un
enlèvement vous mettre en pension sans
même prévenir votre mère et vous passez
et c'est terrible ouais passé neuf ans à
saint louis à montfort l'amaury mais
votre vie désolé
c'est
c'est pas de chance quoi c'est tout quel
âge vous aviez
j'avais 6 ans
dans une institution catholique assez
rigoriste faut bien le dire les
sciatiques celle où les châtiments
corporels étaient de mise
on perd
no coment l'église doit balayer
régulièrement devant sa porte seulement
châtiments corporels
étaient dures
donc vous voyez gentiment bien se faire
cravacher jusqu'au centre de la chine
parce que c'est un troisième qui les
grandes perversion quelqu'un soulevées
par les oreilles
le diamantaire qui arrivait par derrière
parce que je les porte communiquer entre
chaque classe sans faire de bruit ou
voulons pas sur les deux oreilles
en même temps et à trois reprises
s'élancer dur dur vraiment alors vous ne
voyez plus votre mère et en plus vous
entendez du mal d'elle c'est à dire que
vos douleurs et traversée d'un hatem du
style mauvaise mère droguée salle drogué
salle drogué et elle vous cherche oui et
on vous dit pas qu'elle vous cherchent
non et ses lettres on ne remet pas à ton
mais on hermès et après lecture
pas mes parents me disant excuses moi
j'ai ouvert cette lettre par mégarde
alors à l'époque c'est lé premier boulot
vous commencé à bosser writer voit la
première fille aussi pour des
expériences sexuelles il a vous êtes
adoptée par les boulogne c'est à dire
que vous abandonnez votre nom de ps
gagné le nom de nico qui s'appelle ni qu
elle s'applique restart américaine
exactement et donc vous dites cette
adoption c'est le fruit d'un lavage de
cerveau il as a commencé très tôt c'est
à dire dans cette école à la prière il
faut par jour
l'overdose
le catéchisme
et puis surtout ces petits vieux que
j'étais entouré de vieux quoi pour la
reine dieu de la génération de mes
grands-parents quoi
donc qu'ils doivent avoir il ya là plus
à gênés et tu vas en vie à 95 ans
quand vous revoyez votre mère en 79
c'est je dis pas que c'est beau parce
que ce serait un mot malheureux mais
disons que vous êtes défense et tous les
deux et d'un seul coup vous avez une
espèce de communauté ensemble vous avez
quelque chose en commun une drôle de
complicité parce que c'est vrai que des
fois votre mère vous allez chercher de
l'ado pour elle donc j'avais une espèce
j'ai quelque chose en commun ils
trouvent que c'est l'hérault mais c'est
quand même quelque chose en commun c'est
sur une deux trois générations quoi
alors un même époque vous rencontrer
serge gainsbourg oui à l'elysée matignon
qui lui par contre et n'aime pas du tout
ça ouais et cierges vous vous présenter
en tenue de l'oim vous allez vous avez
18 anthony delon à 16 ans vous sortez de
la boîte vous sortez l'elysée matignon
vous mettez sur un banc avenue matignon
évidemment et il vous parler et lui vous
dit qu'il est venu quelques fois joué
dans le sous-sol du pavillon de bourg la
reine et pendant que j'étais en pension
à saint-louis donc à montfort l'amaury
et ils vous racontent mais on partait
donc d'abord dit il venait le mercredi
voilà ma grand mère ils vous racontent
qu'ils empruntent et votre voiture bleue
à pédales voilà c'est pas très bien qui
c'était mais c'est au fils de charcutier
en disait ça ouais on lui disait ça
c'était les jouets du fils de charcutier
dont vous étiez en plus non pas en
secret quoi puisque l'enfant secrets ses
enfants du placard est
alors vous dites à anthony delon il y
avait une gentillesse indéniable de son
côté mais quelque chose ne fonctionnait
pas entre vous parce que quand c'est en
un courant qui ne passait pas vrai
parce que lui quand quand ils vous
raconter ses malheurs pour vous ça vous
semble et quand même un truc pas très
grave parce qu'il était riche quand même
été parqués dans tout
les boîtes de nuit les bouteilles à son
nom elle claquait du doigt ouais
voilà sur il était c'est un luxe ouais
même ça ça ça déroute ces dérives même
son malheur vous semblez quand même un
luxe par rapport à la vie que que vous
viviez oui mais voilà alors après il
faut lire le bouquin c'est un bouquin
très étonnant très bien écrit vous au
nez comme ça entre new york et paris
pendant de nombreuses années la votre
grand père meurt enfin votre grand père
monsieur boulogne ont fait un tube ou
l'autre grand père adoptif honneur vous
rencontrer alain delon lors de
l'héritage enfin chez le notaire et ils
parlent de vous en disant lui il dit
qu'est-ce qu'il aura lui qu'est ce qu'il
aura les bijoux et moi j'ai rien
et vous retombez sur lui un jour quand
vous avez embrassé votre grand-mère à
bourg-la-reine avant de rejoindre nico
en tournée vous dire au revoir votre
grand mère il là vous dites c'est la
rencontre la plus intense que j'ai
jamais eue avec lui et de longs très
bizarrement se comporte avec vous comme
si vous êtes toujours connu à ce moment
là oui mais c'est non
il est tellement bon comédien un bon
acteur que il a
d'abord manger c'est tartelettes
on se retrouve nos problèmes pour pas
qu'on le voit manger
et on m'a ramené à paris en tapant sur
l'épaule ne montrent pas de toi tu es
mon pote mais je vais te dire un truc tu
es pas mon fils sera jamais mon fils
de là jusqu'à paris tamedia tu n'as pas
mes yeux tu n'as pas mes cheveux oui et
pourtant j'ai couché qu'une seule fois
avec ta mère mais ce n'était pas mon
fils sera jamais mon fils et là dessus
j'ai lu dit mais si moi je dois ton avis
mais ce que je dois aussi stipulé qu'il
n'y ait aucun
un rapprochement fait entre nous et là
il me dit ah non non surtout pas tuer ce
terrain la tension
là c'était avant qu'il me déposait à
cela ça c'en est trop passif ouais alors
et vous dépose au métro pas signer avant
de vous déposez il vous dit ton père ses
deux pôles et honte au pollen voilà un
mot extrêmement mystérieuse mais ça son
truc c'est un moment incroyable
donc c'est ton père ses deux pôles et on
vous dit qui ces deux pôles errance et
napoléon c'est tartempion est ce qu'il
n'a pas dit sa poursuite de ma gueule et
je veux dire d'un coup et alors là votre
oncle bernard a émis l'hypothèse d'une
part tous c'est à dire que votre père ne
serait pas sûr d'être votre père parce
que vous serez vous auriez été conçu à
l'occasion d'une partouze sa cc c'est un
délire total quoi c'est
mon oncle bernard n'était pas là pour
voir moi elle reste n'est pas la
chandelle alors alain delon vous laisse
au métro pas si vous ne me pose même pas
de boire un verre non même pas ouais non
moi je pensais qu'on irait boire un café
lance un autre noam dans un rade
voulait plus revu non plus jamais
puisque si si je les revenus à
l'enterrement de lacan maire doit alors
votre meilleur meurt en 88 à ibis à
votre grand-mère en 95 vous avez revu
donc à l'occasion de l'enterrement de
votre grand-mère j'imagine rien de
particulier ce jour là un très froids
comme ça a dit ce temps et tout ça et
aujourd'hui vous vivez avec véronique
oui et vous avez un enfant oui qui
s'appelle charme et sept enfants harry
est allé le reconnaître le jour même
[Musique]
charles la vie continue
harry si alain delon était en face de
vous maintenant vous lui diriez quoi qui
ne me fait pas peur à la c'est la phrase
de pomerol dans le film voilà ce serait
vrai si elle pouvait pas osé lui dire
mais trop passifs
non
plus dur est aujourd'hui nécessaire mais
je dire aujourd'hui ouais tu m'as fait
d'un jeu
je jetterai mon gant si c'était encore
permis aux dix neuf comme au 19e siècle
[Musique]
parce que c'est une manip inadmissible
bon allez
est ce que vous croyez que vous
arriverez à lui pardonner à votre père
bien sûr bon c'est super oh là là et sur
bien sûr moi je suis pas je suis pas
parvenu qu'à donner le dieu
vengeurs quoi foudroyant
lui ferait du bien plus à lui d'être
pardonné par ilham règles à mon pardon
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu